well this has been a difficult time for
local businesses with even more
restrictions in just the last couple of
weeks
so for a closer look at the business
community and how things are going we
welcome vegas chamber mary beth
seawald good morning to you mary beth
it's great to see you
good morning alex it's great to see you
as well thanks for having me on
well thanks for being here i wanted to
start with this most recently governor
steve sisselak
ordered restaurants and bars to cut
capacity from 50 percent down to 25
percent
you know it's been a challenge for many
of them to stay open the past few months
as it was before so what impact is this
now having
well you know it's been a challenge
anything
that takes us backward is is a challenge
for
our businesses small medium and large
but you know i gotta hand it to them
everybody has been doing everything they
could to
comply and to adhere to
you know the restrictions and and the
face coverings and the limited
capacities
and they're really getting creative and
they're doing curbside
service curbside pickup but they're
really working hard to
stay at their capacities and you see the
video it's really tough to see some of
the empty bars and restaurants
that we're seeing and they're trying
really hard
it's it's devastating for some of our
businesses i have to tell you
and some of them are closing up shop but
they really are working hard to try to
comply
do you find the curbside and online
orders is that kind of making up for the
i guess it'd be now 75 because those
restaurants still have to have all the
staff members there the chefs
uh you know in the meantime yeah you
know it is helping and we're encouraging
people especially through this holiday
shopping season
to to shop small shop local
because that really does help our small
businesses to survive and thrive
and you know when when you shop local
you are keeping people
employed in our community and it's so
important to the job market and the
local economy
that we do shop small and they're again
they're getting creative you know
if you you can go online for a lot of
our local small businesses and
and you can buy things online as well
and just have them shipped to you
so it's just so important especially
during the holiday season when
sales make up usually about 20 percent
of retails
retail sales for the whole year so for
small businesses it's critical
yeah absolutely uh you know also in that
same vein in the holiday spirit
chamber has a great program called
switch to kindness the e-gift cards
how do those work mary beth yeah we're
really excited about that program
it's open to all local businesses as
long as they you can sign up
to be a chamber member and we're giving
away free memberships now so it doesn't
cost you anything to sign up
you can see there on the screen we have
tons of businesses who are participating
with that
you can go online at vegaschamber.com
select a business
select the amount and then enter the
recipient's email
and an e-gift card will automatically be
sent
it's a great way to send a gift to your
friends and family or you can also
purchase one for
first responder which was one of the
original reasons that we came up with
the idea back in the beginning of covid
so switch to kindness is a great program
and it's super easy
yeah and gonna support businesses too
you know we are nearly done with 2020. i
don't think anyone is upset about that
so mary beth what are you anticipating
for the upcoming year in terms of local
business you know it's not like a flip
is gonna switch and everything's gonna
go back to normal so
what do you expect to see well you know
it's going to be a continued effort to
keep the curve low it's going to be a
continued effort
to you know we're excited about the
potential vaccine that's coming out now
that's going to be readily available in
the first quarter of the year
and so that'll significantly we think
help us get back to normal
you know in las vegas that means our
tourism and convention industry can
hopefully get back to being operational
special events like concerts and
sporting events can
can resume as well so we're looking
forward to that yeah
fingers crossed the 2021 legislative
session that starts here in about two
months
what is the vegas chamber hoping to see
from lawmakers this session
well this session is going to be
critically important probably
our advocacy efforts at the vegas
chamber are going to be
more important now than they've ever
been our state has some
significant challenges ahead but we have
to be mindful that the number one thing
we can do to get our state back on track
is to focus on economic growth and the
vegas chamber is always on the lookout
for any legislation that
might increase regulations or might cost
businesses even more money at a time
when they really can't afford
any other burdensome regulations you
know those proposals would make it
harder to operate a small business and
and to keep people employed so nevada's
ability to provide
services to our residents depends on
businesses
succeeding and so we're hoping that
legislators are going to keep this in
mind on every single vote they take
um you know and then think about will
these proposals
help employers or hurt employers will it
make it easier or harder to keep their
doors open so those are the things we're
focusing on in 2021 especially as it
relates to the legislative session
yeah they need all the help they can get
mary beth i know you have eggs and
issues
a fun morning event and you had some
news
from this previous event from one of our
congressmen
yeah we did eggs and issues is one of
our premier
government affairs events that we put on
at the vegas chamber about four or five
times a year
this one was virtual as you might
imagine and congressman amade
made the announcement so to speak that
he's considering a run for governor in
2022.
so we were you know very interested and
excited that he made that announcement
uh through a vegas chamber program
and uh we'll wait and see if he actually
does decide to run or how that goes
it's hard to believe we have another
election coming up here in just two
years
so i'm sure a lot will happen between
now and then all right mary beth seawalt
it's great to see you thank you so much
for joining us